foreign
YouTube channel in today's video we are
going to talk about Google business
profile you may remember Google business
profile as Google my business but Google
has changed to name and I'll explain to
you later the reasoning behind this
change we're going to be talking about
what is Google business profile what do
you need to know about it how do you use
Google business profile as a small
business yep and we're going to discuss
many other topics in relation to this as
well but before we start let me
introduce myself I am Mark campman I am
your digital navigator for this video if
you like the video click the like button
and if you want to subscribe to our our
Channel click the Subscribe button below
and you will get lots and lots of access
to more videos and get notifications
about when we publish new videos so
let's dig straight into it let me give
you some facts about Google which will
tell you which will show you that you
cannot afford to miss out on what Google
has to offer you did you know that
Google was visited
89.3 billion times in the past month
only
yeah Google holds over 90 market share
in the search engine Market Google
processes 99
000 searches every second which makes
that a total of 8.5 billion searches
every day
yeah also remember 63 of those surges
are done on a mobile phone
now Google Maps is a key part of your
Google business profile did you know
that there are over 5 billion downloads
of the Google Maps app
and as you find to finalize these
numbers Google generated
146.92 billion dollars in advertising
Revenue in 2020. so do I need to
convince you any further that Google has
to be center stage of your marketing
efforts let's talk how you can do this
when you are a local small business so
what are we going to be talking about we
will talk about what is Google business
profile
how can you use Google business profile
for your local marketing
yeah how do you get started with Google
business profile how can you use your
Google business profile for your search
engine optimization to get a higher
ranking in your Google search engine
results and I'll finish off with a few
pros and cons of the Google business
profile so are you ready let's first
talk about what is Google business
profile it used to be called Google my
business Google has renamed Google my
business to Google business profile to
make it more simple yeah to bring more
of the business profile management
functions out of the Google my business
app directly into Google search and the
Google Map
yep so now the history of the name it's
you currently called Google business
profile you may remember Google my
business before that it was Google
places before that it was Google Plus
local remember those Google days and
when it officially started it was just
Google local
but to keep things simple it has now
been renamed as Google business profile
that you can access through the Google
search or through Google Maps
so how would you define it Google
business profile is a tool that enables
you to manage and optimize your business
profile on Google
yeah so you can create a free business
profile on Google for your shop or your
service area so you can turn people who
find you on Google Search and on Google
Maps into new customers and once you've
created your Google business profile you
can then personalize it with photos with
offers with posts and many other things
and later in this presentation I will
show you how to do all this
so your business profile is Google's
term for your Google Business listing
yeah they appear in Google maps and in
the local results of Google search and
that's very important you can access it
through Google Maps and Google search in
the local search results and you can
also see it on the right side of the
search engine results page
so let me show you an example if I open
up a new frame and I search for Indian
restaurant
yep then here you see the search results
yep you see
restaurants and here you see a map where
you can find those places yeah so that
is in the first place where your
restaurant will show up
yes so if I go then click on one of the
restaurants I can get more details of
different restaurants but also more
details about a restaurant that I picked
yeah and this is what you specify in
Google my business profile
so I could also access them through the
map
yeah so if I click on that that opens up
the same window which more details about
the restaurant as specified in Google
business profile now what is all in
there I'll share that with you in a
minute
so that is the power of Google business
profile
so how can you use this for your local
marketing why is it good to use it to
set up your business profile
Google has reported that 46 of all
searches done on Google have a local
intent
and at business location is the main
piece of information
sought by local searchers
yes so it's the easiest way and the
fastest way for you to show up in the
search feed
so Google business profile gives you the
ability to incorporate your search
engine results into your marketing and
that is a huge Advantage for local
businesses it's not just an ordinary
business listing but it's a robust tool
that gives you benefits from appearing
in the Google search results so if I
would summarize the benefits of Google
business profile they are as follows
they will give you customer engagement
they will help you highlighting your
business in Google
you can gain insights from the people
that visit your website and you can
optimize your online presence for local
SEO
so let's dive into these a little bit
deeper let's start with the customer
engagement
so through Google business profile
customers and Prospects can contact you
and in your business profile you can
specify your telephone number your
address and directions to your business
so people can contact you they can find
you and they can engage with you
say for example a potential lead comes
across your business in the search
results but he wants something special
so how will you reach out to you
directly from the search list
Google business profile has a messaging
feature that lets you directly chat with
potential customers who will find your
profile on the search results page it
enables you to quickly answer questions
in real time and help your current and
potential customers
Google gives you the option to activate
this yes so when you activate it users
visiting your page will see a clickable
message icon on top of that they can
call you or you can add posts to your
business profile to promote special
offers or events and updates to keep
your customers in the loop you can also
reply to public customer reviews to
build trust with new returning customers
and of course you can post answers to
frequently asked questions by your
customers
the second Advantage is that Google
business profile offers you the
opportunity to highlight your business
yeah so it gives you a ton of
opportunities to specify a lot of things
about your business when you sign up and
sign in you get to your dashboard and
that's where you can add items like
showcasing what makes your store special
show photos of your latest products and
your store to stand out to customers who
find your profile yeah you show whether
your offer options like a pickup or a
delivery you can give people who find
you online a warm welcome with posts
about discounts new products upcoming
events so lots of things that you can
highlight about your business again let
me show you an example if I go to Google
and I search for instance for Disney
Paris
yeah you will see I find or let's say
Disneyland
Paris
yes so when I click here on Disneyland
Paris then here I get all the details I
can see the description I can see the
address the rights that you can do the
hours of opening you can see who is
owned by you see events that they have
there's questions and answers there's
reviews yep and there's more information
there's links to social media so lots of
stuff that you can find here as long as
you specified it all on your dashboard
when you highlight your business
so the third benefit is that you can
gain a lot of insights with people or
from people that visit your
um and that find you on Google yeah so
you can gain data about your target
market and your local search performance
you can track your performance over a
given time period and it will give you
insights how people interact with your
business on Google you can check how
often your profile has been viewed you
can use profile views insights to track
how popular your business is with
current and potential customers
yeah not obviously only the owner of the
business profile can view the profile
insights
you will get metrics like the queries
people used to find your business the
number of unique visitors to your
profile number of unique customers who
request directions to your business the
number of clicks on the call to action
button on your business profile number
of clicks on the website link number of
unique conversations through messages
a number of completed bookings by
customers a summary of all your
interactions number of views on products
over a selected period And if you are a
restaurant you can get food orders
placed for pickup or delivery and you
get a number of clicks on the menu
content per user per day so you gain a
lot of knowledge about who what and when
people are accessing and finding you on
the on Google and finally one of the
biggest advantages that you can get with
Google business profile is that it
improves your local search rankings
leading to a higher visibility of your
business on the web
so when you search for a product or
service on Google the first three
listings are usually Google ads
yeah followed by a map with the local
three pack as we call this and then you
will see the organic search results
so let's show you an example of this
local three pack on Google if I go to
search and I search for shoe shop near
me
yeah I'm getting ads yeah that's the
first part and then I'm getting three
places and here is your Google three
pack your local three pack with the map
and then I have the organic search
results
yes so one of the biggest benefit then I
get the search results so for local
businesses prior to this local pack yeah
there were two main ways to show up on
the first page of Google
through local pay-per-click and through
local SEO
now with the addition of this Google
local pack you now have three potential
ways that you could show up on the first
page of Google for Relevant local
searches and that's something that
cannot be ignored now what is this local
three pack it consists of the top three
local businesses based on the searcher's
location
yeah the best part of it is that
customers now end up at your Shop's
front without even having to visit your
websites
so remember this used to be a seven pack
and it's now limited to only three local
listings hence the title the local three
pick
now many many businesses have been
trying different SEO tricks to get into
this special category of three listings
yeah but what most of them don't know is
that by creating a Google business
profile listing you can significantly
increase the chances of making it onto
this list
now there's more that you can do to make
it in this three pack it's important to
get reviews on your Google my business
profile yeah so that helps you increase
the chances of showing up in this local
pack and it's also good for your
reputation which is very important for
your business and Google will reward you
for that with giving you higher search
rankings
and additionally all the SEO rules and
guidelines that apply to standard search
engine optimization they apply to your
local listing as well so think about
your keywords your website SEO getting
backlinks these will all contribute to
your local search listing and whether or
not you will appear in the three pack
now also consider that paid advertising
can help you in getting your business
listed here
yeah through local search ads on Google
there is an opportunity for your
business to serve a local pay-per-click
ad in the three pack
yep and remember just a few tips in
order to show up in the Google three
pack with your pay-per-click ads there's
a few steps that you need to take you
enable local extensions or location
extensions as we call them in Google ads
bit the location and usually sorry bit
by location and use location targeting
and optimize your keywords to include
your location as well
so having your business appear in the
local three pack can help you tap into
potential Revenue opportunities as
Google not only shows customers your
business on Google Maps but it also
places it before organic search results
and let's look at the final topic before
we go into a demo of Google business
profile let's look at a bit more detail
about how Google business profile can
help you with your SEO and what you need
to do to optimize it for SEO
there are three aspects in using Google
business profile for SEO
you need to Target your information by
including your SEO keywords relevant to
your business
you need to make sure you maintain
information quality by ensuring all
information is accurate consistent and
correct and you need to build trust by
engaging with your customers
so to achieve this here is what you need
to do you need to verify your business
you need to fill out your profile
completely
you need to make sure your profile
information is and stays accurate
you must ensure that your nap name
address place is consistent across the
web which is very important yeah your
address is unique across all your places
where you are on the web you pick the
most relevant categories for your
business
make sure that your pictures your photos
are of the highest quality
focus on getting reviews
create posts on your business profile to
drive engagement with your customers and
when customers ask questions on your
business profile make sure you answer
those questions
yeah here you see the importance when
you fill in all the data of the various
Fields you see the most important yeah
there is name address phone number
website link but don't forget the all
the other items as well
so for determining your local ranking
Google takes three factors into
consideration
there's the relevance of your listing is
how well your business matches the
user's search intent
and to increase the chances that your
local business appears in the search
results you should feed Google with as
much information as possible
Google will also look at the distance
yeah so the distance refers to how close
your business location is to the
location of the user who searches
and finally prominence yeah Google
determines your local ranking by
checking out how well known your
business is and whether or not you have
a good reputation
and to influence this reputation you
have off-site links and articles related
to your business they can really
contribute to building your reputation
online
so now that you've got all the details
about Google business profile let's have
a look at how you set it up and I'm
going to show you how to sign into your
Google business account how you can add
your business how you can enter your
location how you can fill in your
contact information I tell you about the
process of verifying your business and
then finally how you can customize your
profile
so let's have a look at Google business
profile if I go to the Google business
profile website then I just go there by
searching for Google business profile
and click on the link that I see on the
search results and then I get to this
page yeah a short summary of what your
free business profile is all about how
you can access your dashboard if you've
got to be a business profile you see
some benefits free easy personalized and
then it gives you all the benefits that
you get from having your business
profile on Google
yes so that is one area where you can
access of course your Google business
profile now the other area where you can
access your Google business profile is
to go to Google Maps so if I go to
Google Maps
and I click here on Google Maps this
takes me to Google Maps if I now want to
go for instance to register my own
business
on Google business profile let me show
you how to do that I can be on Google
Maps I can go to
the place that I want to to register
yeah so and I want that actually on
Google Maps so I don't want that here I
want to stay on Google Maps so let's say
Isis Lake
South Cerny
there is where I have a lodge that I
rent out and if I go zoom in on that
yeah and then here I can see it is
dislodge
yeah and currently there's nothing on
there you see this house has no
business profile this one has
yes so this one has as well so how can I
register this Lodge on Google business
profile very simple I can register it by
right clicking on it
yep so I can get directions what's here
I can say add your business so if I
click here on add your business guess
where that takes me it takes me to
Google business profile and I'm now
going into this setup under my Google
account
yeah I'm going to the setup on Google my
business for this place so the place
name is Isis 97.
Lodge
okay so I click enter and I'm going to
click continue
now it talks to me what is this place
about what kind of business type is it
an online retail is it a local store or
is it a service business let's say it is
a local store because customers can
visit the business in person click on
that and it takes me to the next screen
yeah so I'm going to go for an add-on
enter a business category there's a
whole load of uh categories here I can
say just a lodge or I can say
um what is it a
um a resort let's see if I can do that a
resort hotel yeah or a resort place I
can just say a holiday
sort of
a home
yeah so let's call it a holiday home and
I'm going to click next
now it wants the business address so the
country in this case is not Malaysia
because that's where I am at the moment
so it takes my default address it's in
the United Kingdom the street address is
Isis Lake
and then it is I need to put the address
97 Isis Lake
spine Road
East
East
yeah the post tone is south
Cerny postcode gl75lt
so spine wrote e switches the watermarks
spine Road East I don't mind to share
this data with you because it's going to
be public anyway because people will be
able to find it on the internet yes so
I'm going to click next
what contact details do I want to show
my customers I want to show them the
phone number and that could be 07545
and then three two eight
nine nine nine
is United Kingdom and I can also say I'm
going to skip this step actually for now
I'm going to skip this step
put your business on the map you start
connecting with your customers across
Google all in one place so here are the
details that you've learned earlier in
today's presentation get discovered
respond to review manage your business
details yep and now I'm going to click
do I want to get tips and alerts I'm not
interested in that I just click continue
and here I am in my
dashboard now here comes the process of
verification which is an important
element of Google business profile yeah
so we talked a bit about businesses
using it for spam purposes yeah so the
verification is very important for
Google there are various ways that you
can get verification Google has made it
fairly simple you can verify through a
through a phone number you can also
verify by getting a card sent to your
physical business address
your listing will not show on Google
until you have verified your business
okay but for now I'm going to click next
and I'm going to actually I'm gonna
click verify later because I don't want
to do the verification yet
so now I can add business hours I'm
going to skip that
yeah remember we talked about messaging
I'm going to skip the messaging and now
I can add photos of my business so let's
grab a photo from the internet yep so
let's say Isis Lake South Cerny
and I'm going to go to images
so here is the park where you see images
so I am going to uh take any random
image let's say we'll take
this image
yep I'm gonna right click I'm going to
click save image s and I'm going to do
Isis Lodge om
all right so I'm going to complete my
profile I'm going to add a photo I'm
going to select photo from the computer
I'm going to YouTube and then desktop
and here is the Isis Lodge
yep there's the photo and I can
obviously add a lot more photos there's
the next do I want to start advertising
on Google ads I can actually claim a 400
pounds free advertising credit of course
that is really good what they do here
just to get you to start using
advertising and then get a customer
domain name for a website I haven't got
a website yet but I'm not interested in
that at the moment
yes so remember your edits will be
visible once you're verified all right
so my listing will not be visible yet
but here is basically my besting list
business listing as it stands at the
moment but it is not publicly visible
but at least I have set up my business
profile yeah so now I'm in my dashboards
in Google
my business I had to go into a separate
app for this but now I can actually edit
it all through the search so that is
very useful so here is edit profile read
reviews read the messages
add photos what is the performance do we
want to go advertising all the things we
discussed in our earlier session so edit
profile and here I can get information
about contact information location
information hours of opening my business
name of my launch the opening date
contact information yes so location I
can specify here
so all the details that I need and if I
do this properly is where it will show
up in Google and if I really got my
reputation shorter than everything I may
show up in the Google three pack as well
so that is the process of setting up
your Google business profile so let's
now look at an existing business profile
let's switch my account
so I'm going to sign out of this account
and I'm going to sign in again into my
own accounts
so now I'm in my own Google account and
I'm going to I'm switching the Chrome I
say no just leave it as it is
okay well we can do that
yeah so now I'm in my Google Chrome my
my personal account and I'm going to
show you an existing
um Google business profile that I have
which is for a website for another house
in Marrakech which is Riyadh farasha
yeah so you see here it is already on
Google my business oh sorry it's already
on Google business profile but I haven't
really populated it yet with information
okay so here you can see I can access
this
through the Google search to manage my
profile
yep so I can edit the profile I can read
to refuse all the things that I want to
do I can add an update I can see the
photos yep so here I have access to it
and then here you see the site panel
with a summary of all the things that
you've done
okay I could also access this through
Google Maps again if I go to Google Maps
and I search in Google maps for Riyadh
for Russia
yeah here it is Russia there it will
take me here's the basic details in
Google Maps yeah and it will take me
here to Riyadh for Russia but it is
empty I haven't added any information in
it yet so I can now click here on manage
my business profile or I can see where
um the all the details that I have added
so far
I get some basic data so 55 people
feuded this month and without actually
having done any effort in optimizing it
or populating it with information so if
I hear click on manage your business
profile that takes me back to the Google
search screen where I can add all the
data so let's add a photo I can click
here for add a photo or I can click here
to add a photo I'm clicking here add a
photo I'm doing a photo click here
and then select photo or video and that
is from the YouTube
desktop it's here for Russia 01 it's the
photo that I'm going to add
yep so now I can see the photo
let's see if I can do here you see the
photo
call it
yeah and of course I can add a lot more
I can do a logo a cover a video photo of
the Interior here's a photo that I've
done so far so I can now go back to my
business profile
yeah I think it will take a bit of time
before the photo shows up on the
on the profile
yeah so click add photo
yes so the photos don't show up yet
yeah but that's how you can optimize
your profile making sure all the
information is relevant yep so that is
basically all there is to managing your
profile on on Google business profile so
remember you can access it directly by
searching for your business name in
Google search
or you can exit it access it directly by
entering for searching for your business
name on Google Maps
both show the results and then they also
give you access to your dashboard where
you can add all the information that
needs to be added
yeah performance we talked about that as
well yeah so here you can check by month
you can see I've I've started the um the
created the pro the business profile
sort of the beginning of October so here
you can see I can check from October to
December apply
so I see I had 18 business profile
interactions I can check people that
called me people that message me the
directions people that look at website
clicks booking clicks so you can get a
lot of information
of people that visited your business
profile
okay so that concludes the demo of the
Google business profile and now let's go
back to the slides to give you a summary
of the Google business profile and the
positives and the negatives of it
okay hope you found that useful so let's
finish today's presentation with a few
more facts about the pros and the cons
of your Google business profile we
talked about old approach all the
benefits that you can get yeah and to
summarize Google business profile can
help you with reaching your customers
it can help you responding to customer
interests it can help you respond to
customer feedbacks and you can get into
engagement with your customers and most
important of all it can help you in a
very easy way to get a presence on
Google search results page without
actually having a website
yes so it is of extremely powerful tool
and it's a free tool for your business
to get yourself an online presence where
your customers can find you
and where they can engage with you
but there are some cons as well yeah I
have to think hard about cons but as
most things in digital marketing one con
you could say yeah it takes time
yeah of course you need to set up your
business profile yeah and it takes time
to do that it takes time to maintain
this but I don't see this a considerable
serious drawback
because people that are prepared to put
a time and effort into it they will be
rewarded accordingly
one potential negative of Google
business profile can be that fake
businesses can use it as well because
it's a free service
yeah and although you do there is a
verification process in the Google
business profile yet there may be
businesses who take advantage of this of
this free service yeah so anyone can
realistically set up a profile to
promote their business
so there was an example a few years ago
that fake locksmiths were committing
fraud through local listings on Google
business profile with bogus profiles so
while the majority of the profiles are
genuine businesses trying to promote
themselves in a very competitive World
there are some to see this as a feature
and an opportunity for scams
yeah so people believe that reviews
photos and verifying a business by mail
would be enough to deter scammers
however in this age of fake news as well
as misleading e-commerce reviews Google
must take action to constantly optimize
their verification process of Google
business profile
so that's a wrap a short introduction to
Google business profile and if you want
to know more check out all the other
simply learned courses and if you like
this video click the like button or the
share button and of course click the
Subscribe button below if you want to
subscribe to our channel so you can join
our existing learner community on
YouTube that's it from me now and I see
you at the next video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here